lixian is not
here right not here right now so i'd
like you to meet
i'd like you to meet lunky
[Music]
tape tape hot play if there is a
hole hide you can thanks
yoda all right so this is tape
i seem to remember a familiar intro to a
game such as this one
what am i gonna see big screamer come on
big screamer
screamer
apparently not okay
oh is it is it working oh hello there
welcome to my blog and today we are
delivering pizza
now i know that it it is weird while i'm
vlogging when
i'm delivering pizza however this is the
haunted house in the rumor that people
keep talking about
and i got delivery out of to this house
so let's deliver the pizza to our
customer and see whatever the rumor is
true
also if you like this video please
consider subscribe my channel and leave
a like to this video
you know honestly some people might look
at that and be like oh man you know
that could have been delivered better no
it couldn't have been that was
exactly what someone who isn't the best
at making vlogs
would do and if this was the haunted
house that was
by rumor like yeah this makes perfect
sense plus seal the deal with the sub
and like
please sub and like if you like this
video
like it if you sub this video like it if
you like it
sub it sub this video please thumb sub
and thank you
[Music]
no one at home i guess they did not hear
my knock
well then we shall get back to my car
and give them a call
because i cannot come back to the store
when they haven't received their pizza
yeah what are you ups you knocked twice
and wait a second and then immediately
oh no
not here
what the indeed hey
all right cool i got nothing to say
about this in my life
you're a butthole you're a butthole game
you're a butthole
you're a big bouncy butthole that's what
you are
lmb where am i so dark
and what is this heart
here you may heart you find take you
will
free you gain here fine ta hear the
heart
heart find the heart take the heart free
you'll be
okay also where's my pizza well this is
a weird
black shadow hmm well i hear it over
here
hello hmm
eat a hot why am i hiding why am i
hiding
why did i hide i'm fine okay
oh there it is demon shall rise head
shall fall hide you need look you won't
rud you
shouldn't here it will
you like now can i leave
is that a heart no i can't leave
okay
i knew i knew of his footsteps
okay all clear
oh
that's fine it's fine
fine not 100
all right cool um yeah i'm not a hundred
percent sure
how i'm supposed to be able to get this
with uh
him doing the glide shuffle crossover i
thought it was gonna be a series of
different shots of him going across in
funny ways it would have been so funny
it would have been so
funny this is a birthroom
[Music]
oh oh oh oh
oh oh oh oh oh
can i hide somewhere in here you need to
hide okay good
there it is oh can i get it
toys she loves sing she can friends she
does not play she will
poise she loves
i'm not 100 sure if i'm just supposed to
collect hearts that's weird thing
also my vlog needs more
[Music]
oh
well that was weird
whoa
[Music]
yeah fine totally fine
wow
okay that was fine that's not fine
spoiler alert it wasn't
fine oh no
i would rather not
oh thank you okay i'm just gonna go
can i leave yet
artis beat us oh i
see you're coming down the stairs you
better not be oh he's coming down the
stairs
yeah definitely doing the shuffle down
the stairs
[Music]
where's he going oh fun
did he already go or what's the deal
[Music]
oh
oh good
you [ __ ] what the heck was that you
dick back
okay let's see if we can get somewhere
relatively
safe ish i'm hiding i'm gonna hide where
hide this is great
okay we're okay
huh
another one's pooping ellen's pooping
oh i hear the heart oh
[Music]
i'm in the tub okay so where's that
heart in relation to where i am right
now
it's on the other side of that wall okay
[Music]
okay well where then
oh oh hey
[Laughter]
zoom
hide in the laundry machine
[Music]
okay i hear it
oh fun
[Music]
here here
i do hear it oh there it is
i she tried fail she got laugh they
will well that's cheerful
is there another harder three the magic
number
oh
[Music]
hey
of course you were
i knew that was coming
am i dying is that it
griff is dead good is dead
oh boy yeah okay
shirt shirt stab
stab shirt what am i doing oh there's
another heart
sounds like it's in the garage or
something
i wish i could see
oh really oh okay i'll wait
i'll wait yeah i'll wait i'll wait
thank you wait is he over is he in the
garage
what is that what's that about no
sounds like it's in here
oh it's here lie they do believe they
do hate cheetahs kill she will
i hear it again
it's over there
in the dining room
[Music]
how you doing buddy might be up
might be up above up he stairsy
yeah if he's wandering around up he
stares at you i'm thinking it's probably
upbeat stairsy
you're coming back down buddy
oh yeah okay you keep going that way all
right
you just keep going that way just a
pizza delivery guy
trying to make a living that's
all
[Music]
yeah here oh there it is hane clown she
loves follow she will mistake she made
pain she gained
great i'm not hearing it up here
oh wait maybe i am oh
good thing i checked oh yeah
oh hey hey okay let's
let's all calm down here help me uh
help me you know honestly help me who
needs to help you no one
help me
[Music]
oh hey balloons
great oh where's he coming
oh
[Music]
sounds like it's right here
oh god hello how are you
what are you doing there what you doing
it sounds super it must be down below
then
it's got to be like down below did he
just go down yeah he did where is that
oh in here oh there it is oh
i'm free i'm i'm free
jumping
[Music]
go back to my pizza delivery job
yep i'm a best i'm good
yahoo
i'm not so easily fraterned thank you
for having me
you're welcome that was pretty good i
actually i actually enjoyed that i think
that was very good it was really rough
around the edges but even so like it had
i mean it had screamers and jump scares
but it was still
fairly creepy it had some good mechanics
it was very nice i like that
i like that a lot i did
this is outbreak let's do it and he's
throwing it the wrong way
the power of gordon levitt snap out of
your trunks man
that's better and good shots uh flicks
it to the man at midwicket
throw comes in fbi agent signals are
wise
good for him just happy to be involved
and there's a plastic bag on the pitch
okay all right i don't know what that's
about but um
all right lovely sports i love sports
who doesn't love lovely sports why are
my pictures turned around
what are you trying to hide from me okay
whatever that's just looping through
um a little confused but okay seems like
i drunk myself into a stupor
now i'm gonna stumble my way to bed
maybe
hello
hi wife my lovely beautiful wife okay
sure
tastes like a trap a lovely wife of mine
who's playing piano how you doing hey
good to see you hey you've never
played more goodly than that
wow that was clearly
the most incredible game i've ever
played if you
watched that and didn't hit the like
button as soon as you saw it
are you even human human just
erupt that like button with clicks
for how beautiful that was subscribe
because it was so
unbelievably incredible there is no
doubt in my mind that that was
lixian uh delete everything that we just
saw this is the demon of black hill
cemetery
there it is there you see it hi demon as
an experienced paranormal investigator
or ghost hunter if you prefer i've heard
my fair share of folklore
and can tell you with almost full
certainty that most of it is bogus
however there is always one story out of
a hundred that
has some credibility one such tale is
from the town of black hill
a located in the northernmost region of
washington they say an
insidious demon lurks in the town
cemetery every full moon
and feasts on the souls of those unlucky
enough to enter
several people have allegedly
disappeared there and even the
groundskeeper refuses to enter on
certain nights
i arrived in town recently and spoke
with him myself he claimed he'd seen the
demon
showing me three gashes on his arm to
prove it
i believe this warrants an investigation
although i'm still skeptical tonight
is a full moon and i aim to prove
whether the supposed demon is fact
or fiction okay sounds good lexi and
make sure you put in
well this looks inviting this does look
inviting
if i'm gonna prove this thing is real
i'll need photographs ectoplasm samples
and audio recordings
won't be easy how am i gonna ask this
demon for some ectoplasm
like i'm charming i'm really charming
but i don't know if i can charm some
ectoplasm out of a demon
the first time i made it anyway photos
photos
i can't believe it a cold spot better
take a reading with the spirit box
okay how do i do that what spirit box
who's spirit box where's my spirit box
did i leave it on the truck
where's the spirit box oh how did i do
that
how did i do that how did i do that what
did i press
oh control this is not the spirit box
hello no it wasn't that space
demon why do you haunt these grounds
is that it blood dye
blood scientific flask for any
unfortunate encounters with ectoplasm
or fortunate depending on who you're
asking
can i say it's real
hey buddy oh
what a big baby what a big big boo
okay oh this is the ectoplasm
oh man oh geez oh
gosh oh let me get some ectoplasm
samples oh
that smell ectoplasm
two more samples should do the trick
yeah i know it wasn't nearly enough hey
i'm gonna need a bigger sample if you
know what i mean
ectoplasm man
how do you know the smell of ectoplasm
one more sample
one more uno mas por favor
han bondo juice another cold spot
oh yeah time for a second demon
make yourself known
no no no no
hey what the hell man what the hell
what the hell man all right fine huh
does that sound
sounds like someone's swimming through
an ocean of blood or something am i
supposed to like take a picture of them
that seems prudent i mean they are just
standing there so i guess i should
got it got it
got it nailed it so i just need one more
ectoplasm right
hey give me your ectoplasm right in this
flask put it in the flask
even colder than the others oh i better
do a final reading
okay sure what is your name
that's a funny name demon it's a weird
one die
leave die okay mr leave die
leave the blood what a beautiful name
aha just like this demon's horrified
this
man comes into the graveyard that he is
and he's just like the actor
oh yeah delicious thank you okay you can
imagine why though
i think i have enough if you get some
more i'll take it though
that can't be good hello
you okay you're right bud
this is like a for realsies one
oh boy oh yeah that's for real
i should get out of here hey see you
later buddy
oh is your snooze you lose man
later dude oh my god okay um do i
go now that was close it's time to get
back to the lab
this evidence isn't valuable
i did it me go
i've got goo i got someone that told me
i needed to die
and i got weird pictures i feel
accomplished
okay this was this was a slightly silly
game
i appreciate the effort that went into
this but at no point was it actually
scary it wasn't a scary experience and i
never felt like the person who was
the character that it was was ever in
fear of anything uh but that's okay
because it was silly and i had fun and
at the end of the day that's what a game
should be it's all that matters so
not bad not bad but i'm moving on right
now this is
cabaret cabaret come dance to their
rhythm
when your circle meets when my circle
meets
oh
where's my circle anyone see my circle
it's round kind of looks like a circle
hi is my circle in here
oh okay oh kind of
kind of laggy in here pentagram eyes
hands are they symbolizing something
yeah probably a face i don't know what
they would be symbolizing also
this painting is uh
rough okay hello what good
is sitting alone in your room what good
is sitting alone in your room that's a
good question something about eyes again
exchange a piece of news about a missing
case at the argus hotel
seven artists reported missing a group
of seven artists has been reported
missing after they vanished more than
two weeks ago after checking out of
their hotel room at the end of vacation
the argus hotel which is famous for its
splendid decorations has been reported
several missing cases since last year
yeah splendid decorations
this is what we'll call it splendid it's
artistic i guess
uh bale fires are lighting through all
of the land
the fae folks are dancing their hour
is at hand their music is heard
in the chattering stream they're called
echoes out on the wings of a dream
okay cool nice poem really great stuff
looks like a sun with an
eye or a potato could be a potato as
well a very bright potato but
a potato nonetheless for the life of the
flesh is in the blood
and i have given it for you on the altar
to make atonement for your souls
for it is the blood that makes atonement
by the life
cool fancy words there leviticus man
well this has just been delightful can i
go now
hello oh
is that what i need
[Music]
i don't think the records are supposed
to do that dude doodle at do that i
don't think they're supposed to do that
that doesn't make much sense
embrace embrace deer our eyes everywhere
what are they embracing
i don't know you're supposed to tell me
um
[Music]
okay well i can't leave yet
not that i want to this place is so
lovely
oh hello oh
are those eyeballs
he helped me to see you well not anymore
really hello
open the door okay well i was hoping
that you would
hi who's there
thanks about time big preach on that one
can i go now can i leave this lavishly
decorated place
looks like some sort of rituals are they
witches no they're artists
have you been reading come here the
music play yeah okay
oh wait a minute one of those doors open
probably
okay squeaky elevator
oh
wow art i love art
hello is that an anime wow
good stuff god of seeing yeah
i noticed that with all the eyeballs
what do you collect in there
whoa oh hey
oh hey hey hey looks like an instruction
for something yeah on
off on means i close off means i
on another instruction for something
lost sacrifice return
question x plus key
right hello
wait a minute ah i see i see i see
[Music]
wow i am good i am good
i what is this place
is this a pool this cannot be a pool no
one makes a pool like
it's a pool
it's a pool wow this is something else
anyway just gonna relax by the pool and
enjoy
demon demon do do not not wear white
wear white
demon demon doo-doo no no no okay i'm
out of here
i have a slurp okay so demon demon doo
not not wear white wear white
oh oh oh
oh sums up with this
wait that's not right cabaret admit one
oh the water drained no okay something
tells me if there was actually a
projector or camera down in this pool it
might be a little damaged
you're looking at me hello well this is
uncomfortable
okay i'm just gonna take this a ticket
to a cabaret
what are they performing i need to
collect
oh
ah okay seizure warning yeah flashing
[Music]
[Laughter]
oh
okay thank you i'm assuming those are
beams of light from all the statues
around me thank you very much
that's weird this is weird i'm just now
realizing that this is a little weird
but nothing's threatened me yet so i
think we're okay
long as nothing's waiting for me inside
these doors
yeah okay i'll just go back in then
as if nothing's a problem
okay did i get anything besides just a
ticket to a cabaret that i don't really
know if i want
no that's fine okay
this is more than a little bizarre
oh wait i'm here no come here the music
play that's the same
i'm back i'm back
any doors gonna go flying open on me
apparently not okay
life is a cabaret old chum come to the
cabaret i've heard a lot about this
cabaret but really i don't know a lot of
details about it so if someone could
point me to where it is that'd be
helpful life is a cabernet
oh no oh no life is a cabaret old job
come to the cabaret
oh no oh no
oh no
come to the cabaret life is a cabaret
old jump
come to the cabaret see the goodness
what does goodness stand for i don't
know
come to the cabaret old tum life is a
cabaret
come to the cabaret old tom life is a
come to the cabaret old chum life is a
cabaret
the
was i supposed to notice something about
that did something happen did something
change
i don't know what's happening ah
okay i mean
everything seems fine
weist klu klux klan
oh no
oh ah that's fine that's okay
[Music]
that's fine okay oh my god
hi
okay life is a cabaret old chum
come to the
how are cab doing how you doing
you're good oh god oh
oh oh boy is this the cabaret i've heard
so much about
i've been eagerly awaiting the cabaret
oh seed of honor for me
yes please ah
good hello
oh a door that's what a cabaret
oh
uh my neck my neck
[Applause]
um well i think that explained itself
there's really no need to for me to say
anything about it that was so obvious
and clear
if anyone didn't get it who even are
they
who do you think you are do you even
have a working brain if you understood
what that meant slam that like button to
show that you know
you know what that meant because we all
knew what that meant write a comment
down below if you know what it meant
don't say what it is
don't say what it actually meant just
say if you knew what it meant
that way we'll all know that we knew
what it meant no one could be confused
by that
but that was good i liked it because i
knew what it meant
so that was three scary games thank you
all so much for watching hope you
lunky
hey luxian how you doing
um
right
[Music]
you